what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
and I recently invested in something
that's probably going to absolutely
shock you it is the most outlandish
crazy investment that I've ever made in
my entire life so stay tuned but let me
start with a disclaimer because some of
you might be astonished that I would
possibly do this why would you buy
something so murky and so dirty but
here's the thing as a business owner the
commercial Samuel Leeds knows that if
I'm buying an investment you don't buy a
house that's already a beautiful house
you buy a house that needs a lot of work
even when Elon Musk bought Twitter he
saw Twitter and he saw all these
problems with it and was complaining
about it and then he thought forget this
I'm a multi-billionaire and he just
bought into Twitter and that's exactly
what I have done there is a very large
platform of landlords in the UK and it
is called property tribes I have called
out property tribes over and over and
over for about five years now they
harass people bully people discriminate
against people because of their race
they are discriminative against people
because of their religion I have
personally been trolled and harassed by
property tribes not just the members but
also the owner and the community manager
at property tribes and when I went
through all that harassment through
property tribes and I had to deal with
it and obviously take legal action a lot
of people can't afford to do that
there's people that are being targeted
who are of ethnic minority who feel like
they are being bullied because of their
race they are being watched every day
lied about one of my students who's a
young black man was um lied about by
Vanessa Warwick who's the community
manager of property tribes and the
moderator is her husband and of course
they're working together and he they
said that he was wanted by the police
they have talked about on property
tribes how do we stop tenants moving
into our house because they're not white
it's a disgusting platform in many ways
but you know what it's a massive
platform and I'm thinking rather than
complain about it and call it out you
know what I'm going to do I'm going to
do an Elon Musk and I recently I'm
pleased to say that I have bought in to
property tribes I am now a 25 Owner of
property tribes and the reason I've
bought into it is because I want to
clean up the industry I want to say no
to no to racism
if I make money from this which of
course I will because I'm an owner and
that's how property drivers make their
money from sponsoring from talking about
people getting views and that's and then
sponsorships I own 25 every single penny
that I make from being an owner at
property tribes I'm going to put every
single penny into a charity called stop
hate UK and not only that but I'm
pledging to give 50 000 pounds of my own
money towards these Charities that stop
hate in the UK I mean some of the people
that have been linked to Vanessa what
I've talked about Vanessa Warwick a lot
you can do your own research but Vanessa
Warwick is an advisor on the property
redress scheme that is assisting
landlords publicly how to discriminate
against ethnic minority tenants and it
just makes me think if that's what she's
doing publicly on the Forum what is she
saying behind closed doors this needs to
stop knocked in the property space in
this country can I personally sit back
inside say nothing so I'm putting my
money where my mouth is also there was
people that were connected with a
horrible hate group online they harassed
me and my wife my wife is a black
African lady very beautiful but she was
getting harassed by a lot of people that
were connected to this hate campaign
against me and against other people in
the property community and this is all
kinds of disgusting things to her racist
things
pornographic sexual things very very
disgusting and me and my wife decided to
take action against some of these trolls
and recently there was one guy that was
connected and he was prosecuted and he's
now got a criminal record he was found
guilty of malicious Communications he's
serving he was almost went to prison
he's serving 180 hours of community
service and we had the time and the
money and the inclination and we do have
to deal with Trolls but there's a lot of
people that can't they haven't got the
time or the money or the resources and
stop hating UK one of the things they do
as well as bringing education and
offering support and mentorship and
guidance towards some of these issues
but they also liaise with the police so
if someone's getting harassed through a
company like property tribes which will
hopefully stop shortly I'll talk about
that in a second but if people are
getting harassed and threatened and
bullied online especially if it's
because of the color of their skin or
their um their religion or their sexual
orientation it's just wrong and
sometimes the police are so busy that
they don't do anything about it so stop
hate UK one of the things that they do
is they assist with the police to
actually take these things in front of a
judge which I think needs to happen I
think there needs to be consequences
when you've said things that are very
very Twisted that are sickening that our
racist that are malicious there needs to
be consequences so a property tribes not
only am I going to be because I don't
have control complete control over
property tribes now okay I only own 25
so I can't just go in and moderate all
the comments and things like that but
what I can control is I can control the
profits I can control what happens with
the money that property tribes makes and
that is why I'm going to be given 25 of
all the profits that property tribes
makes I'm going to be given to stop hate
UK I didn't actually want to make this
video I wasn't planning on publicly
saying I bought 25 of property tribes I
was trying to use my influence quietly
I'd invest in lots of companies quietly
and do lots of things behind closed
doors quietly to try and bring change
however it was leaked because Vanessa
went on to
um she was having an interview with a
solicitor called Lucas and he brought it
up and he was like what do you think
about Samuel Leeds buying 25 properties
am I right to say that Samuel Leeds owns
property tribes
or owns part of property tribes
the samueline says owns 25 of property
tribes so
I thought in some way you were
well
I'm sorry you're not aware of that no
and it shot me that she had absolutely
no idea I mean especially when she
Prides herself on due diligence due
diligence um or the due diligence module
due diligence we're going to talk about
a subject very close to both our hearts
and that is due diligence what I do
which is due diligence and of course due
diligence it was it was quite amusing to
see and then he brought out the
documents and everything and it was it
was an absolute train wreck so if you
want to see the full interview I'll
leave a link below and you can check
that out she also said lots of other
things that just made me think she
should not be an advisor on the property
redress scheme I mean in my opinion I
think Vanessa needs to step down as an
advisor on a property redress game I
think that she needs to stop being a
volunteer in my business property tribes
in fact Vanessa world doesn't own any
shares in property tribes she's a
volunteer so she works for me I am
technically Vanessa Warwick's boss
because I own shares in the company she
doesn't she works for me and I think
that she needs to quietly step down and
resign as a community manager volunteer
for property tribes and also think that
she needs to stop speaking at the
national Landlord Association units I
think it's wrong and the last thing that
she spoke at I don't know if they're a
racist organization she spoke a couple
of days ago there was 18 speakers and
every single one of them was white you
know and we know what her views are but
I'm going to leave a link below of the
interview I'm also going to leave a link
with the website where I put an article
a little bit about some of the stuff
that Vanessa said some people are saying
it's not racist what she said and I'm
thinking how can it not be racist to
advise somebody to an assist them to
literally
get around loopholes of discriminating
against people purely because of the
color of their skin because they're from
Bangladesh because they're from India
because they're Gypsy she's done this
um I think it's just completely wrong
I'm a landlord myself she's not even
doing property she hasn't bought any
property since 2009 so she's not
actively in property she's not buying
things yet she's helping people
discriminate she works as a volunteer
for me I just think it's time that she
steps down so anyway guys I hope you
enjoyed this video and I will see you
next time check the links out below
peace out God